hi in this video we are going to talk
about the pituitary gland pituitary
gland is roughly one centimeter in
diameter and it weighs about one gram
and it is situated in a bony cavity
known as sella turcica at the base of
the brain now the pituitary gland is
anatomically divided into two distinct
location anterior pituitary otherwise
known as Adreno hypothesis and the
posterior pituitary otherwise known as
new hypothesis anterior pituitary give
rise to hormones such as prolactin
growth hormones gonadotropins thyroid
stimulating hormones and adrenaline
cortical tropic hormones now the
posterior pituitary give rise to
oxytocin and vasopressin in between
these two locations and tirion posterior
pituitary there is a thin line like
structure which is known as pars
intermedia
which is underdeveloped in case of
higher primates but in lower animals
this is bigger now they're not only
different in terms of their anatomical
location but also their developmental
origin is different so roughly we
simplify the pituitary diagram like this
which is appears to be hanging from the
hypothalamic region and there is
anterior pituitary and the posterior
pituitary now during development the
anterior pituitary develops from a
embryonic structure known as rectus
pouch which is a protrusion of NASA
pharyngeal epithelium so it's a
epithelial lineage now the diencephalon
ik group also gives rise to a protrusion
which ultimately devlop develops into
the posterior pituitary that means it
has the neural lineage now the
diencephalon II protrusion
increase in size so as the rat case
pouch protrusion and ultimately the rat
Chris pouch is pinched off the
protrusion from Radke pouch is pinched
off and the anterior pituitary is formed
and the posterior pituitary appears to
be a continuous book crucial
the diencephalon accrue and that is how
the pituitary gland development takes
place however let's look at the hormones
of the anterior pituitary anterior
pituitary give rise to thyrotropin with
stimulates the thyroid glands it gives
rise to cortical droppings which
stimulates the adrenal cortex it also
give rise to gonadotropins
which in effect some Gounod's then
Soumitra droppings secreted from the
anterior pituitary regulates growth of
the bones
whereas prolactin secreted from the
pituitary helps in breast development
and lactation now let's take a look at
the cell types and the basic histology
of the anterior pituitary so let's take
a cross-section of the pituitary gland
to understand that so here is the
cross-section of the anterior pituitary
and we can see different histological
zones and this demarcation is depending
upon the cell types so here we have the
tyro Trop cells which secretes
thyrotropin or TSH now there are
symmetric ropes cortical Tropes
lateral tropes and Gounod shrubs so
tight rope secrets
TSH or thyroid stimulating hormone which
acts on the thyroid gland to secrete t3
and t4 now cortical droplets secrete
ACTH or adrenal cortical tropic hormone
which stimulates the adrenal cortex to
secrete the corticosteroids now somatic
drops secrets
Soumitra dropped cells secrete growth
hormone which acts upon big bones and
help in bone development or bone growth
lack to drop secretes prolactin which
helps in lactation and breast
development now cuñado drops
secretes FSH LH or i CS h hormones
molecule stimulating hormone luteinizing
hormone or interstitial cells
stimulating hormone all of that can act
on GU nuts for example FSH works on
follicles in the ovary where as I see SH
works on the seminiferous tubules and
help in small production and sperm
development now let's look at the
relative abundance of these cell types
for example the somatic drops are the
most
abundant cell types present in the
anterior pituitary approximately 30 to
40 percent of the cell types present in
anterior pituitary is the somatic trops
whereas 20% of the cells present in the
anterior pituitary are the cortical
drops accreting ACTH other than that
tyro troves laptops and Kannada drops
comprises five to ten percent of the
other cell types present in the
pituitary so pituitary has the posterior
division as well let's look at the
posterior pituitary for a glance now
posterior pituitary have neuronal input
from periventricular and super optic
nucleus and the hormones which are
secreted from the posterior pituitary
are oxytocin and antidiuretic hormone
about them we are going to learn in a
totally different video now the overall
phenomenon is the hypothalamus impulse a
top-down control because hypothalamus
releases several releasing hormones
these releasing hormones impose a
top-down control on the tropic hormones
secreted from the pituitary and thereby
this works like an hypothalamic
pituitary axis so either hypothalamus
pituitary gonadal axis hypothalamus
pituitary thyroid axis so this is how
the whole hormonal regulation takes
place and there are several feedback
loops ensuring proper secretion of the
hormone and preventing over secretion or
over secretion related complications so
about that view I'm going to I'm going
to make a part two of this so keep
watching and do subscribe my channel if
you like this video give it a big thumbs
up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe and do let me know how you
like my videos in comments thank you